Hi, this is Taryn from
Somerville, Massachusetts.
Radiolab is supported
by dash digital cash.
The quick and easy way to send money to
anyone in the world from anywhere in the
world.
Dash arrives within seconds
and transactions are instant
secure and optionally
private dash is digital
cash. For more information,
visit [inaudible] dot org slash radio lab.
Hello, I'm Jad and I am Robert.
This is radio lab and today our topic
is tinkering I guess tinkering with
nature. Yeah. Or life.
Yes. But Don as we know it,
no cause before the break we heard about
some kids doing something that they
call yes.
Directed evolution by sticking wintergreen
into a place where wintergreen has
never been before, which definitely
qualifies as life, not as we know.
But now it's getting to the
true grit of this cause.
Those kids are looking at life in a,
in a fairly different way
than most of us do. Yes.
It's very interesting that the people
who are creating these living systems are
engineers. This is Lee silver from
Princeton University. I mean they,
they really look at a living system
as no different than a computational,
uh, electronic device. And you, your
hunches there. Right. My hunters,
they're wrong. I don't know quite why
by hunches, they're right. But, um,
most of the world doesn't believe that
include me because I find it very
hard to imagine that that a life
[inaudible] animal leaves it for
a span of years and then dies.
You know, it's like when they die
and the spirit kind of goes out.
It's hard for me to believe that that is
just a chemical machine or
several from parts. Really. Yeah.
Okay. I mean, I guess
I can understand that,
but let me introduce you to
a guy now who's whole, uh,
admittedly young career is based
on the idea that life is a machine,
that it's made of parts, parts that
he can build and sell. Okay. So I'm,
I'm Brian Banes. Brian,
we met actually just down the street
from those MIT kids. He is 31.
That's right. Just 31. And he
runs his own biotech company.
I'm one of the founders
of code on devices here.
We make custom synthetic genes from
scratch and he's doing pretty well.
The industry is gray, sickly doubling
every two years. At this point. I mean,
just to give you a sense of what
Brian does, you with me? Yup.
Just take your example. Those MIT kids,
let's say I'm one of those kids or someone
else who's heard about them and don't
want to take my stinky bacteria
and make it smell better,
or maybe I want to make it glow. All
I have to do is call Brian. Sure.
Because he'll sell me a simple gene
like that for about 1500 bucks.
I just have to go online. Look
up the chemical recipes for
dark. Yes. Here it is. 1200 letters,
t, G, Z, Cesar, letters of DNA, g,
a t and a c of for fundamental
building blocks of DNA. The next,
just list out those A's,
g's and t's and C's. Yeah,
just type them into an email. Generally
they're not typing it themselves.
Imagine trying to type in 2000 letters
by hand without making a mistake and that
would take too long. All right. Just
copy and paste them into an email.
Send them to Brian g. When
we get that in house, we, um,
we're going to take that into our factor.
Sorry.
Brian then plugs the string
of letters into this machine,
which is about the size
of a desktop computer.
We have a synthesis system
where it literally has a
bunch of little A's in a jar
and a bunch of gs in a jar and,
and t's and C's. Now mind you,
these chemicals are in Irt. They are
store bought $100 a bottle. The machine,
they're all connected to reads all
the letters that Brian plugs in
and when it's using a machine,
eh, squirts out some a
TV [inaudible] warts out some t test,
we can add an a or a g or a t or
a c to a growing strand of DNA.
And so we literally adding
one base at a time, C, c.
So what starts as one letter pieces
then grows to 50 then grows to maybe 500
then grows to be 5,000
and at a certain point,
all of these inert chemicals hold hands.
And that's literally how
you make DNA chemically.
That is how you go from dust to
something that is not exactly alive,
but if I take this little speck of DNA
and stick it into my cell, amazingly,
it will start to glow or smell better
or whatever it is that I wanted to do.
It will do it.
It's almost as if the cell is a
computer and this little bit of DNA is a
software program. That's the way
synthetic biologists think about it. Hmm.
And what synthetic biologists are
hoping for us as Lees, that the,
the software, quote unquote, we'll get
standardized. It will come down in price.
So that one day installing new features
into organisms will be just as easy as
when you install new
software on your home PC,
put a word processor or you put a
spreadsheet program user-friendly.
That's kind of the logic.
Yeah, but that's not the,
that's that we're talking about life
here. Life isn't like, you know,
a game of Legos. What if it is,
I mean I know it's weird to think it's
wrong in other words to describe it,
but what if it's not wrong?
Just imagine you can start to look
at things in a completely new way.
You can look at that
creature over there and say,
that creature right there has a talent
that I really like and that went over
there. The second one, it
also does something cool.
Maybe if I take talent one and
talent to stick them together,
put them into a third creature.
Then I've got a little factory.
They can do really cool stuff.
Free eight living things that have
very important functional values.
As an example, in our earlier
conversation with Lee silver,
he brought up a guy named George Church,
George Church as a scientist
at Harvard medical school.
He's thought to be absolutely
brilliant by everybody that knows him.
We actually haven't have a picture of
George on emoney and he showed us, Oh,
is that him? That's him. He typically,
he doesn't click a radical. Let me see.
Let me see what his face
looks like. This guy,
then he's wearing an
army shirt of some kind.
He's got a nice bushy
beard and a spit curl.
It would be Santa Claus
played by Clark Gable. Well,
we had to visit him. Hi, how are you?
And George is unusual as scientists go.
I'm George Church professors genetics at
Harvard Medical School for the last 20
years.
He's been going further and further and
further in terms of synthesizing life.
Okay, I'll slide. You do what
I'll do. I'll slide. He he's,
he's stuffing some kind of big black
rod up my nose. That would be the mic.
Now the kind of creatures,
the George Church engineers are the same
kind of those MIT kids use eco lie by
taking these little tiny
Nikolai and you know,
adding a few genes from other organisms
and tweaking the internal chemistry.
He has gotten the
Nikolai to suck in sugar,
which is what they normally like to
eat. Poop out all kinds of things.
Most notably drum roll please. Diesel
for real. Oh yeah.
Some mean the company I co founded
has produced hydrocarbons status.
Just a fancy way of saying
among other things, diesel,
three different kinds to run in
three types of engines, cars,
trucks and planes. I was
curious to see how it all work.
So he took me to a room at the back of
his lab where he's perfecting the process
and he pointed to a small container. So
here's an example where we might grow,
grow up a large batch of of
cells in a, in a fermentor.
So this big vet right here, which is,
I dunno what's the size of a
couple of liters? Pretty small.
It's about the size of a coke bottle.
And right now he can
only make a few drops.
So there are some scale issues
to solve. But I asked him,
you were to close your eyes and you know,
where does he imagine this stuff going
project forward into the future and he
painted. Describe it for
me. What would it look like?
An amazing picture of
huge bodies of water.
Giant pawns or lakes of gas.
I mean just imagine we could take a boat,
paddle around and be beautiful birds
chirping except under the [inaudible].
Trillions of bacteria would
be busily eating plant life,
burping out diesel fuel,
which then float to the surface
as this kind of gassy foam.
And you can skim it off, skimming off
through into a pipe. There you have it.
I mean this could be the
oil refinery of the future.
No more pumping in out of the ground and
fighting wars. I get that. That's old.
Now we're talking
microbes, man. Mike Rowe.
And this could be just the beginning.
I mean according to Lisa silver,
people are hoping that this kind of
bioengineering can produce all kinds of
stuff. You know, a drug that cures
malaria. Something that makes plastic,
I mean anything. Well I
they would be good. Yeah,
there is part of it that makes
it look me a little uneasy.
Why and and well I wanna introduce
you to another bioengineer.
He's often called the leader
of the pack, like the rat pack.
Sort of like the rat pack.
His name is Craig venter and like the
rat pack folks. He's very talented.
He's very ambitious. He's very driven.
He's also working on a bug for fuel.
He also thinks that the earth is in
trouble. We're messing our nests,
something terrible. And when we were
at the 92nd street y in New York,
he said to them right out loud,
bio engineer creating new
life is our last hope.
It's probably our one major chance of
having our species survive on this planet.
I mean this is the engineering of the
rest of this century and that's a little,
I mean stand aside young man,
I'll rescue now with my magical scientific
ability and my natural engineering
skills. Kids Save the world. I
stand aside and throw them a parade.
Well except that you don't realize just
how ambitious these these guys are.
What's wrong with
ambition? Nothing really.
But what you don't know is
just how bold this guy is.
He not only wants to mix and match
traits that already exist in, in,
in life to make new forms of life.
He wants to do original design.
He wants to think of things
that life has never done before.
Things that are in his
head that are entirely new.
He even dreams of life life form
from, from scratch, from scratch,
completely like 4.1 billion years
ago. Kind of like in Genesis.
It'd probably take a
little longer, but, uh,
I think there will be new life for forms.
You think it will be possible in your
lifetime that someone will go into a store
by dust,
figure out what it is that they have to
do with that desk so that what they make
will be unmistakably alive,
not alive than alive.
Yes. Yes.
But using the knowledge that we have
from studying this 4 billion years of
evolution, we don't want
to write about what,
what if I told you that I thought no,
I don't know why. Just, no, I
think you reviewed my grant.
No, but there's a,
there's a candidness to scientists
that that puzzles me a little bit.
Isn't there something that you think,
and this would be really close to it,
creating life that just
might be out of our grasp.
It might be forever and mysterious
and, and yet you guys like, I mean,
is there anything in the
way of, of engineering life,
is there anything that
you think is not doable?
Do you think it's never going
to happen, that you'll meet,
create a conscious life form from scratch
or it will never happen that you will
create a morally or you know,
a sense of a creature with moral sense
of right and wrong or, I don't know.
I think you think that everything
is possible. Everything.
I think you're right.
[inaudible]
okay. I get that cracking people
like it might have a little bit of a,
of an attitude about they can accomplish,
but is that your problem than he did
he, it's his attitude. No, no, no, no.
It's, it's a sense of life
I think is wrong here.
I really appreciate because of
Darwin and Darwinian evolution,
but it takes 100 million,
200 million a billion years for creatures
to figure out how to live in the
neighborhood of life, how
to know what would fit in,
how you know if you're going to sustain,
you got to learn how to live
harmoniously with the rest of nature.
It takes awhile, but here come these
engineers over some weekend thing.
I have a new idea, maybe
the lead oil or audible,
and then you stick it into the world and
you've just stuck something into a rich
fabric of life and you have no idea of
all the different consequences that could
follow from that decision. Oh look,
look at what happens right now with
antibiotics. That scientist Nigel Golden,
whom he heard from, you know, before 50
years ago, we declared war on microbes.
We, we fed antibiotics to cattle, to
kids when they had virus infections.
We put so much antibiotics into our
bodies and into our food that the bacteria
we were trying to kill figured out a way
to avoid our medicines and now they're
stronger than ever. Not Smart.
We didn't know they were things that we
didn't really understand that we didn't
know, that we didn't understand, and
we're paying the place for that. Now.
I am frightened that these people have
so much ambition and so much certainty in
them that frankly, they don't fear
what biologists don't know about life.
It's a really a Frankenstein story
that is there so much hubris in this.
And as Steve Strogatz will tell you,
biologists and peck scientists
in general know veer.
We now know how much we
don't know about life.
If biology really is
about collective behavior,
the interaction of billions of molecules,
billions of species that
has network of, of life.
We barely understand. You know, we
keep being surprised about life.
On the one hand we can tinker in this
engineering way like the MIT students do
or like venter is doing.
But on the other hand,
the best biologists are still mystified
that we only have about the same number
of genes as a worm.
We're really still missing
99% of the picture, literally.
So it's a scary time today to
start playing Dr Frankenstein,
given how ignorant we are.
Do you know that at Stony Brook University
where your mom worked for all those
years, there was a scientist,
maybe a few doors down from your mom who
who made from scratch using good dust
particles? We've talked
about the polio virus,
which the whole world has
been working to eliminate.
Polio made a new polio
virus. Why? I don't know.
There was a lot of controversy about it,
but there is a guy could perhaps in the
cave somewhere in Afghanistan who wants
to make a polio virus and who will
use it against this [inaudible].
Yeah, yeah, you're right. You're
right. You are right that there is,
there are some bad things
that can happen. Very bad.
So the question is then what? Like what
do you do in the face of that risk?
How do you proceed? Do you
say to these guys, stop.
Would you have these guys
stop doing what they're doing?
Stop doing their experiments.
Asking questions, being
curious. Oh, that'd be ridiculous to
tell the science not to do science.
So what then I,
I don't know. I mean I
don't, I don't know exactly.
Do I want them to, to
not do experiments? No,
I'm not saying don't I,
so I'm not going to be a troglodyte
and say we shouldn't play with these.
And Steve Strogatz agrees. I think
it's great to play with them,
but I'm scared too. I don't know. I'm
confused about it because we have to play.
That's how we make all science, you know,
they speak of Homo ludens human
beings as the player that we,
we are what we are because we like
to play with nature, with ideas,
with language. This is how we
learn things. So we're gonna play,
but we have to be very
careful about how we play.
And we don't want to fall into the
idea that we know more than we, we do.
[inaudible]
we have a vast ocean to
discover it before us.
[inaudible]
okay, well I guess that's
all the time we have. Um,
anything that you heard this hour that
you want to hear again, more information.
It's all on our website, radio lab.org.
Any creature you'd like to build already
designed for creature that you'd like
to build or any monster that you have in
your head that you'd like to make into
wheel living flesh. Send that to us
too. Yes. While you're on our site,
send us an email as well. Radio
lab@wnyc.org is our email address.
I'm Jad Abumrad I'm Robert
Krulwich. Thanks for listening.